Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my Doctor Who Episode 11 video. If you
didn't know, this is the first part of a two
part finale. So there is one more episode
next week. Just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet rule number one
of dying don't rule number two slowdown was
to take a poll for best Mind Palace between
Sherlock and Doctor who of course the TARDIS
is going to be the doctors my palace but actually
before we get started this is a new round
of the giveaway starts now oriented enters
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so superhigh concept episode that answered
a bunch of questions I think the thing I was
most happy about you know in addition to the
big twist or that it actually gave us some
really big answers especially the hybrid and
the confession dial is a really two of the
three big reveals in the episode there are
three big reveals the last one being what
was on the other side of the confession dial
so top five WTF number five the doctor materializes
in a mysterious tower that reconfigures itself
the way they play the episode you think he's
been trapped there by someone else but then
you gradually learned that it's a close energy
loop in it's a trap of his own design I'm
trapped in a puzzle box with no way out or
I could be in hell it must be Christmas all
I could think about was River song when he
said that although I knew she wasn't going
to be in this episode the set design of the
castle was amazing the way they make it feel
so grand and claustrophobic at the same time
it's it's a perfect episode for the doctor
being by himself like of one person episode
despite the fact that we have this creature
the dolled I guess I'll just call the veil
like we have the doctor in the veil eventually
we find out that it really is the doctor by
himself the veil is just a device of the confession
dial sidebar if the confession dial is the
last will and testament of their free timelord
does that mean the confession dial being a
backdoor to Gallifrey is something that every
timelord has access to or is this confession
dial just unique to the doctor somebody and
Moffat on the phone it reminds me a lot of
the episode listen from series 8 we get to
see the doctor by himself working out problems
on the chalkboard but what is the doctor do
when he's by himself while he talks to himself
a lot but the twisted and onto my number four
WTF is that Clara speaks to him inside the
TARDIS Mind Palace so Clara did come back
but she is mine Palace clutch is completely
a creation of his mind I think it's a really
fitting way to memorialize heard that this
episode itself was kind of a memorial to Clara
just because the doctor thinks about her so
much the hard part isn't the dying it's every
day thereafter that they stay dead who else
thought it was a little mysterious that his
handwriting was so perfect on that blackboard
that's the minute I was like okay this is
probably Clara's handwriting they made the
reveal later on and she ends up speaking eventually
and then touching his face but is on his mind
and deeper in the episode to do this weird
thing where the blackboard is actually inside
the castle so it's really hard to tell whether
the doctors reimagining himself running through
the castle or if the blackboard itself is
inside the castle is such a high concept episode
is so much fun it is the doctor slowly starts
to figure out the mechanism of the castle
it starts to become this big medic commentary
on Doctor who is a series in general those
are my favorite type of Doctor Who references
when it when it starts referencing itself
but it also becomes this medic commentary
for the series is a whole like how long can
I keep doing this the doctor examining Doctor
who even though mine Palace Clar is really
the doctor talking to himself it becomes this
big reaffirmation like yes you must go on
can I lose this once no no you can speaking
of mine Palace cut twos let me know which
cut was your favorite like when he jumped
out the window at the first time he digs that
grave in the veil almost grab some images
slam cuts to the mine Palace TARDIS will that
was a close one on my number three WTF the
doctor discovers that the only way to stop
the veil is to make confessions which makes
sense now that we know that the veil was the
device of the confession dial just the confessions
in general were amazing especially early on
before he starts talking about the hybrid
fine I did leave Gallifrey because I was bored
I was afraid that's really the point where
the episode starts to get really scary it's
it's not so much like him realizing that the
Clara painting is 7000 years old it's once
he starts to put the pieces together of the
close energy loop the stars are all in the
wrong place how long of I've been here so
on my number two WTF the doctor realizes that
it's a close energy loop in the he's the only
one in the prison and he's been there for
forever all the schools belong to him that's
the moment when the episode stops being comedy
horror just starts being pure horror the doctor
was that mysterious figure at the beginning
of the episode that plugged himself into the
transport device to pull another copy out
is that big called action I'm not can it tell
you anything more about the hybrid and starts
punching a way at that diamond wall he actually
says it's like 400 times harder than diamond
they just want you to know that it's supposed
to be impossible for anyone to break through
like he can't just smash with anything so
he just starts beating away at it with his
bare fist he suddenly recalls the Brothers
Grimm lovely bellows in the story about the
Emperor how many seconds in eternity and we
get that amazing montage of the doctor just
going through the same events over and over
and over with his great soundtrack primary
gold probably the best soundtrack from any
episode of the series you can actually just
listen to the music but after 2 billion years
or so he finally beats his way through the
wall of time so to speak it seems like a physical
thing but so much of the episode is high concept
and mental it becomes this metaphor of him
beating his way through time like I'm never
going to stop this is big reaffirmation for
Doctor who is a series like you how many times
can we do this well we can keep doing this
for forever what's 2 billion years to a timelord
I feel like that's a big way to the fandom
like we are never going to quit there will
always be some form of Doctor Who but he beats
his way through the wall and informs this
portal out of the confession dial on to Gallifrey
and everyone's like oh my Cairo like slips
their ship so course on my number one WTF
the doctor calls himself out as the hybrid
you had a prophecy before the time war that
a creature would arise a hybrid half dalek
half timelord the dollars so would never allow
that to happen I confess I am the hybrid destined
to conquer Gallifrey and stand in its ruins
if you haven't flipped your desk over and
excitement yet I feel like this is the moment
let me know when you guys figured out that
he was on Gallifrey the book before the camera
turned around to reveal the city for me it
was really when he told the boy to run to
the city like when he gave in that message
tell them I'm coming and I want my way will
say most immediate threat the episode knew
he would probably end up on Gallifrey I just
didn't know how would happen I didn't realize
that the confession dial would be the McGuffin
to get in there what you guys think about
the confession dial though how did you like
that McGuffin like that being a backdoor to
Gallifrey is a whole other questions that
they didn't answer hopefully that will address
some of them in the finale but I just love
the imagery of the confession dial is like
a big pocket watch like the doctor was traveling
through his pocket watch to get back to Gallifrey
2 billion years definitely the long way around
the really icing the doctor being the hybrid
is more reference to him being half human
that's really something that they addressed
during the 1996 movie if you never watch the
Doctor Who movie should check it out at some
point is actually a quote that Moffat gave
in reference to the doctor being half human
to talk about the eighth Doctor Innes says
keeping in mind that everything you know for
sure is probably wrong answer me this in which
story isn't confirmed definitively that the
doctor is not human at us for Moffat so mouth
see can take it however he well but that mesh
is what I took the imagery of the hybrid to
be in this episode hear my big questions for
you guys let me know in the comments how did
you feel about the way they wrote this episode
just the style in general and what you think
about the McGuffin of the confession dial
the way they used it as a backdoor to Gallifrey
why guess think about that here some of the
Easter eggs in the episode so one there is
no TARDIS in this episode although he thought
there might be a TARDIS behind that wall there
was no TARDIS for a giant portion of third
doctor episodes when he was in exile on earth
but is also mission to the unknown the sun
tarn experiment Genesis of the Daleks and
midnight those are other really big episodes
where there was no TARDIS of course the doctor
gets back on Gallifrey soil by the end of
the episode the first time he physically traveled
back to Gallifrey was a second doctor episode
called the wargames they ask him why he ran
away and he said well I was bored so Capaldi
sang in the steps of confessing I wasn't bored
I was scared is a big reference that second
doctor episode but we did next to learn the
name of the planet was Gallifrey till a much
much later episode called the Time warrior
and is not really an Easter egg which is the
refund behind-the-scenes fact about making
the episode the actor the place of the veil
is the same actor that played colonies start
factoring magicians apprentice in which is
familiar depending on what happens in the
actual finale we could see some references
to the fourth doctor because Tom Baker actually
did travel back to Gallifrey without a companion
so there have been Doctor Who episodes with
him back on Gallifrey by himself but I just
love the tease at the end of the episode as
if he's going to conquer Gallifrey and stand
on its ruins so all in all great episode I
really I really hope the last episode episode
12 really sticks the landing we do have the
Christmas special but that is really going
to be its own thing like it's on River song
story the other big thing you need to keep
in the back of your mind is who is going to
be the new companion Moffat is probably already
found them but we might not see them until
series 10 episode one semantics videos gonna
be episode 12 next week then I'll start doing
some Christmas special videos I know a lot
of you been asking for some Sherlock Christmas
special videos all start doing that too especially
once we get into December congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner the Supergirl
you and a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info just in case
you haven't seen there's been a whole bunch
of trailers drop in the last couple of days
you can click here for the Captain America
Civil War trailer and you can click here for
my Doctor who series 9 playlist thank you
so much for watching, everybody high five
and I'll see you guys later tonight long way
around!